let's go next to johnny from boston
johnny welcome
hey david
um a question in regards to the trans
women in bathroom legislations i've been
going around and sure quite frankly i i
don't feel like they really are honest
with the language because if
i feel like they're playing on
the
prejudices of voters and of maybe
ignorances of what trans people are do
you think that's done willingly or do
you think that they're people who really
don't understand what like trans issues
and trance rights are well give me what
do you what do you mean what's the
language that you that's in the bills
that you think doesn't consider the
reality of trans folks so
they talk more about like though we're
going to have trans women in bathrooms
and then it's like we're going to go
you're going to only have the people in
the bathroom of their biological sex
assigned at birth however
they're not thinking of the reality is
that that means trans men who look and
present as men are going to end up in
women's bathrooms if they go
right like they don't feel like they're
thinking this out you're absolutely
right and so what you're basically what
you're pointing out is that if you just
make a rule that basically says
you've got to go in the bathroom that
matches your biological sex at birth
there are plenty of trans women now who
they to the av i'm trying to use you
know
careful but respectful language to the
average person you see these individuals
and you go that's a woman you you either
you would have no particular reason to
say that's not actually a woman as i see
it if they are forced to go to the men's
room it's going to be just as confusing
of a situation you can also take take
the opposite uh and talk about trans men
as well so you're completely correct and
the issue is they don't really care
about that they just care about having
what they see
as the morally and politically correct
rule
um that goes along with their
pre-existing worldview they don't care
about the practicality or reality of it
yeah and it's and i and i also i am
frustrated with people who are gops who
who say that they're trans allies and
don't speak up
like that's that's hot garbage yeah they
should that like i see people like megan
mccain not say a damn thing about it but
oh is that right
yeah and she claims to be a like an lgbt
ally you go you know t means trans right
use your platform a lot of people you
know for for a lot of people
being an lgbt ally means they have one
lesbian friend you know
right or they want to watch drag race
like that's literally
right very well said johnny thank you
yeah thanks that was it there's johnny
and boston great to hear from you as
always
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far
vincero sunglasses and jewelry and other
accessories are awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below